bernier d'échauffement pour bruno car
dans quelques jours sa moto partira pour
cape town en afrique du sud il la
rejoindra en novembre pour l'aventuré ou
louent une expérience unique quarante
jours de raids et cinq pays à découvrir
les autos simba beau et zambie botswana
et namibie
au quotidien bruno est chef d'entreprise
dans le bâtiment mais son temps libre
c'est aux sports mécaniques qui le
consacre lorsqu'il quitte sa bécane et
les pilotes des avions tous ces sports
là c'est l'évasion avant tout c'est
effectivement aller au revoir à
l'extérieur ce qui s'y passe côtoyer
un tas de gens de
paysages différents ces voyages c'est
avec sa femme qu'il va le vivre c'est
elle qui les a inscrits auprès d'une
entreprise tourangelle spécialisé dans
les raids à moto très bien moyennant dix
mille euros par personne la société
prend en charge l'organisation complète
du voyage un soulagement pour ces néo
aventuriers ils ont tous un gps ou un
téléphone sur leurs motos ils ont un
tracé qui doivent suivre impérativement
nous on a un ouvreur à l'avant donc
c'est à dire que ils peuvent qu il ya
toujours quelqu'un devant et toujours
quelqu'un derrière donc à partir du
moment où ils sont sept traces ils sont
toujours encadrées donc s'il ya une
casse mécanique une casse physique ça
arrive aussi de la fatigue des choses
comme ça eh bien il ya toujours
quelqu'un qui sera là pour pour pour
fermer la marche et et retrouver les
personnes qui au moindre souci quel
qu'il soit et pour éviter la case
physique le couple s'entraîne depuis
plusieurs mois course à pied et
renforcement musculaire pour eux c'est
aussi le défi sportif ilsont chalenge
que je me donne
je ne sais pas je pense que cette phase
de confinement à cette situation très
anxiogène a fait que j'avais envie de me
dépasser dès qu'on retrouverait nos
libertés le
voilà j'ai envie de profiter encore deux
fois plus de la vie
top départ de l'aventuré au loup le 7
novembre prochain